et d'autres invités politiques ce soir
c'est françois bayrou bonsoir bonsoir si
bonne année bonne année aux idiots vous
êtes le patron du modem et le maire de
pau évidemment on va parler de ce qui
vous concerne mais avant cela la gauche
c'est la dernière ligne droite pour
cette primaire de la gauche avec des
candidats qui défilent qui dévoile au
fil des jours leur programme est ce que
dans ce qui a été dit pour l'instant par
monsieur peillon valls à montebourg il
ya quelque chose qui vous intéresse et
une idée nouvelle qui suscite en tout
cas il ya une chose qui m'intéresse et
qui n'est pas une idée nouvelle c'est
qu'on annonce des dépenses par centaines
de milliards dans un pays dont on sait
qu'elle est la fragilité des comptes je
vous rappelle que l'engagement qui avait
été pris par françois hollande c'était
qu'on retrouve la barre des 3% dès 2013
et qu'on soit à l'équilibré en 2017
on en est très loin on vient à peine
d'atteindre la barre des 3% et encore
les instances de contrôle 10 mais c'est
pas des chiffres qui sont sérieux et
tout le monde annonce des tombereaux de
dépenses et moi ça me laisse extrêmement
sceptique on a l'impression qu'il ya
comme ça une espèce de le concours
d'entreprises industrielles de chaque en
blanc travers vos pensées universel par
exemple proposé par benoît revenu
universel
reste à savoir si c'est une bonne idée
ou pas mais ce qu'on annonce c'est 300
milliards pour le financer l'avs est ce
que ces 300 milliards a du mal à se
faire une réalité du mal donc c'est
c'est tout ceci serait très sympathique
si on était un pays avec des comptes en
pleine forme
une économie rentable où tout le monde
donnerait le
le maximum de lui-même mais c'est pas du
tout la situation et ce type d' annonce
a eu un effet à mes yeux
harry's ou présentent un risque colossal
qui est que ça va détruire un peu plus
la confiance que les français peuvent
avoir dans leur pays et que le reste du
monde peut avoir dans la france est-ce
que vous pensez que ça aussi
institutionnalise le fait qu'on va
rester dans une société de chômage de
masse et que donc pour s'en sortir il
faudra ce revenu minimum d'existence
je pense qu'il ya ça dans l'esprit d'un
certain nombre de gens qui considèrent
que le travail au fond c'est fini moi je
veux pas du tout partagé ce sentiment je
suis persuadé alors vous me direz c'est
un optimisme un peu idéaliste
je suis persuadé qu'on peut améliorer
beaucoup la situation du pays par une
organisation différente du pays
pas en distribuant de l'argent qu'on n'a
pas et je suis sûr et peut-être vous
l'observez vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de
scepticisme parmi les français sur ce
concours de promesses qui parraine
jamais être achevés entre les hommes les
autres
les baisses massives d'impôts pour les
uns les promesses illusoires pour les
autres moi je trouve qu'il ya là quelque
chose qui est enfin qui portent atteinte
à ce que la démocratie doit avoir de
vérité normalement normalement
démocratie c'est un contrat de vérité
entre les responsables élus et le peuple
des citoyens
normalement quand on dit quelque chose
ça doit être sérieux pesée est respecté
et on en mettrait très loin non pas que
je ne pense pas qu'on puisse faire des
choses vous savez que j'ai proposé une
idée nouvelle qui est le droit à une
première expérience professionnelle
parce que quand on est jeune et qu'on
sort de l'école au fond il ya deux
sortes de situations ou bien vous êtes
diplômé vous avez une famille qui a des
relations quitte
ses confères reveint trouvez un job ou
bien vous venez d'un milieu qui n'a pas
ses relations ou bien vous n'êtes pas
diplômés et vous ne trouvez rien et
chaque fois que vous postulez un emploi
qu'est ce qu'on vous dit on vous dit
mais vous n'avez pas d'expérience
mademoiselle monsieur vous n'avez pas
d'expérience et bien cette idée nouvelle
qui est une idée qui elle est finançable
parce qu'il ya des dizaines de milliards
destinés à la formation professionnelle
qui sont gaspillées qui sont enfin je
sais pas en tout cas dont on n'a pas
l'impression qu'ils servent à changer
les choses
cette idée nouvelle elle est finançable
et ça répond à ce projet que j'essaie de
défendre
qui est on peut faire beaucoup mieux
dans la situation de la société
française sans détruire l'équilibré de
nos comptes
c'est une question d'organisation et de
vision différente de penser différentes
de l'avenir un droit effectivement la
première expérience professionnelle
juste encore un dernier mot sur la
gauche vincent peillon a provoqué une
polémique hier soir je sais pas si vous
l'avez entendu ses propos sur la laïcité
on va les écouter vous allez me dire
c'est ça vous choque pas si certains
veulent utiliser la laïcité ça a déjà
été fait dans le passé contre certaines
catégories de population c'était il ya
quarante ans les juifs à qui on mettait
des étoiles jaunes c'est aujourd'hui un
certain nombre de nos compatriotes
musulmans qu'on amalgame d'ailleurs
souvent avec les islamistes radicaux qui
s'est acquis soyons marine le pen ne
fait que ça est-ce que ça me choque
franchement je pense qu'il faut pas
comparer ce qui n'est pas comparable
d'abord je vais vous dire quelque chose
il ya beaucoup de musulmans qui
aimeraient qu'on les regarde comme on
regarde tous les autres français croyant
pas croyante
si on pouvait considérer que ce n'est
pas une question la religion qui doit
entraîner des discriminations je trouve
que ça irait beaucoup mieux et donc non
je vraiment je ne compare pas le front
national avec ce qui s'est passé hélas
dans la période la plus inquiétante est
la plus noire de la guerre de 40
il ya des propos qui sont pas
acceptables mais ils sont pas que du
côté du front national entre noah c'est
si vous regardez le paysage politique il
ya beaucoup de gens qui essaie
d'instrumentaliser cette histoire de
religion et donc je fais la différence
entre les uns et les autres
alors justement est ce que vous faites
allusion au fait que françois fillon m
lui très clairement en avant sa religion
hier il disait sur le plateau de tf1 je
suis gaulliste et je suis chrétien
est-ce que ça ça vous choque
franchement qu'est ce que ça à voir en
parler de la sécu si j'ai bien compris
et il dit je peux pas porter atteinte à
la sécu par ce que je suis chrétien mais
qu'est-ce que ça à voir c'est je suis
croyant je vais pas
comment dirais je m'offusque et de d'un
mouvement de fois mais comment peut-on
arriver à mélanger la politique et la
religion à ce point de cette manière
déplacée le le principe de la france
c'est qu'on ne mélange pas religion et
politique
c'est que l'on considère que les choix
politiques sont différents ou
indépendants des choix de la religion
qu'est ce qu'on dirait sur disait je
peux pas porter atteinte à la sécu par
ce que je suis athée ou rationaliste ou
juif ou un e autre religion vous
comprenez on a l'impression qu'on en est
à un point en raison d'un certain nombre
de dérives
on en est à un point où on considère que
tout doit être l'objet d'une
instrumentalisation politique et moi je
suis pour que on est des principes qui
soit respectée et qu'on dise dans notre
pays on ne mélange pas les questions qui
sont des questions intimes de d'adhésion
religieuse deux fois de conscience
d'athéisme ou de croyance on ne les
mélange pas avec la politique ce sont
deux domaines que nous avons séparé et
que nous avons séparé depuis plus d'un
siècle lorsque c'était le principe de la
laïcité française estimé que françois
fillon instrumentalisent la religion est
ce que c'était à des fins électoralistes
à votre faim écoutez je n'arrive pas à
comprendre
franchement si vous m'interrogez je
connais françois fillon depuis longtemps
je n'ai
je n'ai jamais vu faire des déclarations
de cet ordre donc ça doit être lié aux
élections d'une manière ou d'une autre à
ce qu'on croit être un corps électoral
et moi je me refuse à regarder les
croyants comme un corps électoral les
athées comme un corps électoral les
agnostiques comme un corps électoral
je ne comprends pas qu'on se laisse
aller à ce type 2 de dérive là je trouve
que qu'il faut mettre un terme à ces
mélanges déplacer alors vous êtes dur
avec françois fillon vous avez
d'ailleurs en début de semaine démenti
tout pacte secret avec lui un puisque
dans la presse on estimait que voilà
votre retrait l'élection présidentielle
serait monnayée à la faveur de postes de
sièges tous les styles laurence ferrari
disent ouverts à de nouvelles à vous
aurez observé que tous les jours il ya
des articles qui disent les uns ça y est
on en est sûr françois bayrou a décidé
de s'allier avec fillon ou bien ça y est
on en est sûr il va s'allier avec macron
où ça y est on en est sûr il va se
présenter
il se trouve que c'est aucun des trois
j'en sais rien a probablement y at il
une des trois qui qui est juste mais
mais la vérité m'oblige à vous dire que
j'ai décidé de prendre le temps de cette
décision d'avoir mon propre rythme
pourquoi parce que comme tous les
français et ceux qui nous écoutent
j'observe que tout ça est un bazar
absolument incroyable de sans précédent
que on a l'impression que d'un jour à
l'autre tout change des vocations
naissent ce retable love là moi je
préfère attendre que les choses se
décantent
et à ce moment là je me poserai je ne
cesserai de me poser une question est ce
que les choix proposés aux français vont
dans le bon sens
s'ils vont dans le bon sens chez une ou
l'autre de ces hypothèses
alors j'en tiendrais compte et s'ils ne
vont pas dans le bon sens eh bien je
prendrai ma décision en toute conscience
c'est-à-dire bonne décision dépend du
choix des candidats de la primaire de la
décision
on dépend de la situation dans laquelle
on place le pays au moment de choisir
son avenir
moi je trouve que en france ça ne va pas
bien je pense que ça pourrait aller
beaucoup mieux que ça pourrait aller
beaucoup mieux dans le respect des
équilibres que ça pourrait aller
beaucoup mieux avec une autre pratique
politique et un autre type de présidence
de la république
je pense que la clé de voûte est là
l'exercice du pouvoir l'exercice du
pouvoir en france et désaxé
alors je souhaite leur est accessible je
puis faire un néologisme avec vous alors
en ce qui concerne françois fillon
connaît son programme
on connaît à peu près à priori sa vision
de l'exercice du pouvoir il l'a
longuement évoqué lors des débats de la
primaire de la droite elle ne vous
convient pas il ya des choses qui vont
voir là dedans ben vous savez bien quels
sont les points sur lesquels jour
désaccord avec lui françois fillon il
dit je suis ce set chez rien je suis
dans la ligne de madame thatcher
je suis moi persuadé que c'est pas
madame thatcher qu'il faut à la france
aujourd'hui je pense que la france
aujourd'hui a besoin d'être soutenue
d'être rassemblés et que l'activité
reprenne et madame cette chaire le les
choix qu'elle avait fait comme vous
savez ils ont fait un million et demi de
chômeurs nouveau la première année je ne
dis pas qu'elle n'ait rien fait de bien
moi j'ai pas aimé qu'elle laisse mourir
les gens de grève de la faim chacun ses
choix je pense que la démocratie c'est
fait pour discuter et pour empêcher que
on est des glissements de cet ordre est
donc oui je ne me sens pas représenté
par la ligne cette chaire excusez moi de
dire j'ai connu françois fillon qui
était un proche de philippe séguin
gaullisme social
vous vous souvenez le matin bleu
la fracture sociale c'est le mot qu'il
avait inventé
c'était le contraire du cecce rythme et
je pense qu'aujourd'hui la france a
besoin de cette énergie nouvelle et elle
a besoin de gens qui est de la cohérence
au travers du temps en tout cas moi ce
que je souhaite défendre
est-ce que emmanuel macron ne répond pas
en partie au voeu que vous formez alors
dans cette nouvelle vidéo de la france
l'exercice si vous savez ce que dit
monsieur macron vous propose alors vous
êtes plus forte que moi et donc j'écoute
j'écouterai et puis je regarderai
qu'elle est enfin si la question si
importante de de la personnalité de
l'expérience et remplit tout ça c'est
pour moi des questions ouvertes vous
voyez bien il n'y a que des incertitudes
alors on va adopter une ligne assez
simple on va réduire les incertitudes et
après la réduction des incertitudes et
bien des décisions devront être prises
et c'est normal qu'elles interviennent
dont d'un délai de leslie février vous
travaillez un livre programmatique un
livre de témoignages un livre testament
sur les hypothèques ce traitement mais
vous avez une vision qui est une vision
un peu noir de la situation et moi c'est
un livre qui traduit qui traduira une
vision de ce que la france est et de ce
que la france attend pour pour trouver
son nouvel équilibre et je pense qu'il
ya de grands changements à apporter et
pas nécessairement ce qu'on nous propose
est ce qu'une nouvelle candidature à la
présidentielle n'est pas une adventure
les ports surhumain ont tout vu non
franchement non ce je vais vous dire les
élections l'élection présidentielle est
un moment formidable de rencontres avec
les gens
que c'est le seul moment politique en
fait on vous écoute vraiment puis c'est
le moment où des millions de gens
viennent dans le secret de l'isoloir
ayant réfléchi en conscience ayant
interrogé leurs leurs idées et leurs et
leurs attentes et peut-être le côté
affectif de ce qu'ils sont ils viennent
et il met votre nom dans une urne
il y en a acheté 12 millions qui ont qui
ont voté pour moi dans ces échéances
c'est un moment de rencontre
extraordinaire avec la france c'est
quelque chose de profondément
passionnant mais pour autant c'est une
décision qu'on ne peut prendre quand
responsabilité c'est pas on fait pas ça
pour soi même pour sa préférence pour
ses goûts pour ses passions en fait ça
parce que on a là l'impression ou la
certitude que ce qu'on doit dire
personne ne le dit mais ce que vous ne
redoutez pas de manière crédible comme
nicolas sarkozy ou françois hollande les
français on sort les sortants et bien je
ne suis pas seront partenaires de demi
ça tombe bien je ne suis pas sortant je
ne le suis pas je n'étais pas la fois
précédente non plus il se trouve que bon
j'aime est arrivé d'approcher le seuil
de la sélection mais bon je n'ai pas été
choisi et je suis sûr si vous faites
dans votre mémoire
le bilan des problèmes que j'ai soulevé
et des idées que j'ai défendue sur ces
dernières années alors vous allez voir
que tous ces problèmes là au bout du
compte la réalité le le jugement de
l'histoire comme on dit parfois le
jugement de la justice ont donné raison
à la plupart des positions que j'avais
prise c'est par découragement ça c'est
un encouragement
merci beaucoup françois bayrou si elle
est revenue ce soir sur i télé dans un
instant enfin par météo le journal
9h30 là tout de suite